a shocking field hockey injury at a
school in Massachusetts a sparking
debate over just that issue a female
player accidentally struck in the mouth
by Point Blake shot from a male playing
on the opposing team the incident
causing outrage among her fellow
teammates who were left traumatized
they're begging the state to change
their Equal Rights Amendment which
allows male athletes to play on girls
teams if that sport is not offered in
the school for the boy judge I'll go to
you first um that's a weird
interpretation of the Equal Rights maybe
they've written it that we in
Massachusetts but is this is this what
the Equal Rights Amendment there was
intended to to do I haven't read that
equal rights amendment but the way
they're interpreting it is they're
basically saying that um the Equal
Rights Amendment uh uh says that you
cannot deny someone participation in a
team based upon gender okay so to me
I've always been offended by the
transgenders I've always been offended
by the Leah Thomases swimming as women
against women okay but this is worse
because you're not swimming in your own
lane this is literally combat and these
men who historically are stronger than
women that's the end of it being allowed
to compete with women in this kind of
sport is um is dangerous and I'm not
surprised at what happened now I'm sure
she was wearing a mouth guard apparently
her injuries were so horrible whether it
was accident or a guy who was so
confident I'm going to show these women
you know how to play um it just the
whole stadium apparently was traumatized
by what happened she lost teeth she lost
I mean she was all full of blood I mean
this is very serious so you've got men's
lacrosse women's lacrosse you've got
field hockey let the men do their own
field hockey and in a situation where
there is combat men should not be
allowed to play in women's sports you
share the judge's view uh Jesse you have
two daughters that compete I know in
swimming yeah this isn't some slender
way out there at his first game this guy
is a co- captain and he's fouryear all
County jeez so he's winding up and just
smacking the shot and I had the brain
room look at this a female volleyball
player she spikes at about 50 miles an
hour a male volleyball player can Spike
at 80 so back up what about softball
female softball player can hit the ball
55 mil an hour a male softball player 90
mph so if he rips one straight back into
the pitcher's face I mean forget about
teeth hits you right here you could die
can I mean this is putting women's not
just records in danger their lives in
danger Dan you know football some women
are playing on men's football teams in
high school and even College they're
usually kickers right but but some some
are Ro in the game not a lot of contact
no no but I don't disagree with how do
you how do you how does does that make
you think about this any different way
not really I think that adults can be
reasonable here and as I covered it this
morning so there in Massachusetts it
does say if there's not a field hockey
team for both genders and they Everybody
Plays together it just seems ridiculous
and it doesn't feel like you have to go
through the whole court system and have
an election to decide that this is not a
good idea that actually happened to my
sister in a co-ed softball game uh she
was playing I believe third base and
took one right to the Head from uh a guy
and this in Colorado there's a lot of
these co-ed teams and May and I know
this may be a fluke thing but it meant
she never played again and she was very
fortunate she had a great EMT surgeon
who did um some stitches for her but it
could have been much worse it was much
worse for a volleyball player in North
Carolina because one of those guys
spiked the ball it changed her whole
life she was on track to get a
scholarship at a four-year school that
she wanted to go to she didn't get to go
to that school oh so it did change her
livelihood and her future Greg your
thoughts on this yeah I look at this
stuff Case by case that's how I roll
yeah you know because I'm in the
news uh I don't mind co-ed Sports it's
kind of fun like we used to play co-ed
softball a pickle ball very popular
among the co-eds at The
Villages uh cornhole that's fun co-ed
but there you you cannot there's an
effort to erase distinctions between
male and female which ends up hurting
both Sexes But ultimately you're seeing
now it's more so on women in women's
sports men happen to be better at some
things than women and women have happen
to be better at some things than men but
you can't say that right and that's kind
of where we are right now where you can
break a woman's nose or teeth under the
guise of gender Equity I don't know
about the case here cuz frankly I don't
care about field hockey I didn't even
know what it is until today they don't
have field hockey in California when you
grew up no yes they did no they don't I
don't think they really had it in
Colorado until recently East Coast
Hockey is what rich people it's not
that's lacrosse up next how Tech is
turning us into mindless zombies hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else